votre invité sonia mabrouk c'est le
sénateur les républicains de vendée
bruno retailleau président du groupe plr
au sénat bonjour bruno retailleau
bonjour sonia mabrouk le sénat
majoritairement de droite a voté hier
sans surprise la proposition de loi de
républicain interdisant le voile en
sortie scolaire et plus largement les
signes religieux l'assemblée nationale
ne vous suivra pas c'est donc une portée
uniquement symbolique
oui mais c'est une portée qui est
importante puisque nous l'avons très
majoritairement voté tout simplement
pour les auditeurs qui nous écoutent
on a des règles à l'école qui sont
street avec la loi de 2004 et aussi avec
une jurisprudence de cet été les parents
qui vont à l'école bas ils ne peuvent
pas avoir de signes ostentatoires et on
considère que la sortie scolaire c'est
la prolongation de l'école c'est l'école
hors les murs et donc les règles qui
s'appliquent à l'école dans les murs
doivent s'appliquer à l'école hors les
murs pourquoi est ce qu'on demande des
jeunes filles d'enlever leur voile quand
elles ont à l'école pourquoi est-ce que
leur mère leur aîné n'en ferait pas
autant pour une sortie scolaire
franchement c'est la laïcité c'est la
république et je pense que il faut
réaffirmer aujourd'hui au moment où le
communautarisme est en train de gagner
des territoires dans les polices
françaises il ya des principes
républicains
serein qu'il faut absolument réaffirme
serein dites vous après l' attaque de
bayonne certains vous ont reproché de
manière générale d'avoir maintenu
l'examen hier de votre proposition de
loi avec le risque d'alimenter bruno
retailleau un climat tendu voire
inquiétant que leur répondez vous je
leur réponds que si justement nous
n'avons pas le courage de poser des
règles républicaines très claire alors
on risque d'avoir des confrontations
dans la rue je pense qu'il ya une
inversion de valeur il ya une formidable
aversion de valeur s'est rappelé les
principes républicains qui diviserait la
république il faudrait donc que la
république renonce à ses exigences mais
mais on marche sur la tête et notre
famille politique n'a aucune leçon quand
on parle de contexte le contexte pour
nous c'est 2004 c'est nous qui avons
fait voter la loi interdisant les signes
ostentatoires à l'école c'est nous qui
en 2010 avons fait voter la loi contre
la burqa
donc voyez ya une longue histoire et
bien sûr que l'actualité peut percuter
un agenda législatif mais pour autant ça
n'est ni l'émotion ni l'actualité qui
doit dicter sa loi
sympa
ce que vous dites vous nous dites ce
matin aucune de son voici la phrase est
fière d'edouard philippe nous devons
faire très attention et lui aux
responsables politiques à ce que nous
disons ça c'est quand même comme un
rappel à l'ordre ça vous choque
ce rapport de cause à effet entre le
débat et plus largement ce qui s'est
passé à bayonne ce qui me choque c'est
un gouvernement à présent de république
qui parle qui parle qui parle qu'est ce
qu'il a dit est ce que vous vous
souvenez le 15 avril 2010 8 mg/l macron
devant un journaliste de bfm devant un
journaliste de mediapart qui a cette
phrase le voile n'est pas conforme à la
civilité dans notre pays c'est à dire
aux rapports entre les hommes et les
femmes
il dit ça il ya un an il dit tout et son
contraire
donc moi j'attends du gouvernement non
pas qu'ils prononcent des sentences non
pas qui parle fort mais qu'ils agissent
et franchement les sorties scolaires
franchement c'est le minimum qu'on
pourrait en attendre et on a quelque
sorte la preuve qu' il ne souhaite rien
faire il ne souhaite rien faire sur ce
sujet comme sur beaucoup d'autres
médiums qu'on aurait pu attendre est ce
que vous ne diriez aussi de jean michel
blanquer refasse avoué hier au sénat le
voile on se souvient de sa frappe n'est
pas souhaitable et ne doit pas être
interdite vous comprenez sa position
mais je sauve parce que tous ceux qui
écoutent et le déballe pour jean michel
blanquer
et pour était au rouet macoutes et on
voyait bien que il y avait des
convictions et puis qui soutenait une
position qui avait fait l'objet d'un
arbitrage ou dessus de lui il avait même
dit il avait été plus loin que nous
j'avais dit le voile n'est pas si
souhaitable non pas dans les sorties
scolaires
mais dans la société et nous on lui
disait mais non mais le voile doit pas
exister parce que on doit protéger des
enfants qui sont des consciences en
construction donc il faut des règles
d'une neutralité et et malheureusement
il a dit non à ce petit cette petite
chose c'est un ministre de l'éducation
nationale qui n'est plus en cohérence
avec ce que pense le présent de
république
non mais je peux importe je dire je veux
pas personnaliser simplement ce que je
dis c'est que aujourd'hui un islam
radical qui est en train qui veut
construire une contre-société à visées
séparatistes et nous teste y teste les
principes de la république
et en plus il retourne nos propres
valeurs comme la liberté d'expression
contre
principes laïques et républicains et il
faut pas être dupe ouvrir les yeux
je constate kemmel macron paix tout ce
plan est justement n'a pas la majorité
ce qui vous fait dire bruno retailleau
qu'est ce qui vous fait dire précisément
que sur l'islam politique sur le
communautarisme que le président n'ait
pas suffisamment conscients de ces
dangers qui nous menacent les feux je
pense qu'on doit juger un politique non
pas à ses discours et les discours des
mails macron sont souvent fort et ils
sont souvent brillant je pense qu'on
doit le juger
au fait comment se fait-il qu'en même
que depuis des semaines on a eu un
attentat dans le coeur de la république
française dans le coeur du service qui
va nous protéger du terrorisme
il ya quatre fonctionnaires de police
qui sont morts et parfois dans des
conditions extrêmement violente et vous
vous rendez compte que des semaines et
des semaines après on a décidé deux
enquêtes administratives
c'est tout rien de plus et vous avez
raison mais on ne comprend pas je ne
comprends pas en quoi interdire le voile
en sortie scolaire bas nous prémunir des
attentats islamistes
est ce que vous comprenez pourquoi
est-ce qu'en 2004 on a interdit le voile
ou au jeune fille c'est la même chose je
veux simplement nous voulons au moment
où l'islam radical est en train de
tester la république nous voulons poser
des limites parce que si on pose pas ses
limites c'est ça monsieur blanquet nous
l'a dit mais on est dans une situation
hybride on va faire du cas par cas
ça veut dire qu il se défausse sur les
directeurs d'école moi je ne veux pas me
défausser sur le directeur d'école et
quand la règle n'est pas clair la loi
doit sereinement mais fermement l'a
réaffirmé le signe ostentatoire pour
influencer nos jeunes enfants bruno
retailleau est ce qui peut y avoir
prochainement en france selon vous à la
faveur des élections municipales des
élus étiquetés communautaire bien sûr
ils peuvent gagner mais ils peuvent
gagner dans certaines villes on a dans
le val d'oise par exemple comme
garges-lès-gonesse comme goussainville
un cette rampe d'interrogations et il
faut agir il faut pas à tangente en d 1
min je crois que c'était sébastien le
corps d'huile year we made you qui
seront élus on pourra peut être
sanctionné si j'avais dont trois en
combat politique et il ajoute pardonnez
moi c'est cette proposition qui va faire
au chef de l'état le contrôle par les
préfets de chaque arrêté d'un maire qui
pourrait prêter à confusion
le contrôle du mégalithe attendez je
suis luge voilà j'étais présent d'un
département d'une région d'une
intercommunalité chaque délibération
fait l'objet effectivement est envoyé à
la préfecture pour un contrôle qu'on
appelle de l'égalité bon une autre avant
chaque délibération et on le regardera
mathématiquement non non bien sûr que
non ce que je veux dire que c'est après
il sera trop tard parce que pourquoi ça
sera trop tard
vous imaginez ma mère communautariste
qui s'empare d'une commune et on veut le
sanctionner après il appellera ses
troupes à manifester et ce sera le
désordre et ce sera là le comment il
reste des affrontements donc ce que je
pense moi c'est qu'il faut agir avant
c'est l'objet de la proposition de loi
que je vais déposer au sénat dans les
jours prochains pour interdire justement
ces candidatures ces listes a visé
communautaire penser que juridiquement
cela ce tient absolument vous en avez
donc des garanties
vous savez vous savez je me souviens
très bien campés ria munk omri a fait
passer dans son texte
un article de loi pour que les
entreprises puissent intégrer dans leur
règlement intérieur une restriction
justement la liberté religieuse
vous saviez il ya eu déjà la crèche baby
loup bien eh bien monsieur bianco à
l'époque était président de
l'observatoire de la laïcité ça c'est
anticonstitutionnel c'est contraire à la
convention européenne des droits de
l'homme et le conseil considère validé
donc en france il ya une manie pour ceux
qui sont peu courageux c'est d'en
appeler avant même qu'une loi soit votée
à son caractère anticonstitutionnel bien
ça c'est une forme d'intimidation
juridique
croyez-moi je l' ai vécu au moment du
black blocks on m'avait dit nan nan mais
prend des comptes
vous ne pouvez pas interdire aux
manifestants de se cacher le visage
qu est ce qu a dit conseil conscio neil
que j'avais à dire vous êtes en pointe
dans ce combat bruno retailleau et la
question que je vais vous poser très
sincèrement n'est pas politicienne mais
pour comprendre jusqu'où vous allez
mener votre combat si au sein de votre
parti sis au sein de républicains ces
valeurs ne sont pas suffisamment porté
un carnet à votre goût en vue de 2022 ce
que vous iriez vous même au combat oui
c'est une question je me poserai jeu
simplement bien mais je vous la pose
aujourd'hui si je mène avec combat si je
mène ce combat c'est parce que j'aime
mon pays parce que je pense que la
spécificité française c'est aussi la
république française qui donne
à chacun quelle que soit sa religion
quelle que soit sa couleur de peau les
mêmes chances c'est pour ça que je mène
ce combat et je ne veux pas qu'il y ait
des amalgames
je mène ce combat aussi pour protéger
nos compatriotes musulmans qui
pratiquent une foi musulmane compatible
avec nos valeurs je ne veux pas qu'on
les mette dans le même sac voilà c'est
aussi pour eux que on doit les protéger
du radicalisme islamique est en train de
gagner dans les esprits et parfois sur
le territoire français c'est donc des
sujets qui vont selon vous incarnez
marqué notamment la présidentielle et
probablement que je combats l'angle mort
des mains de macron c'est tous les
sujets régaliens c'est le sujet de la
sécurité c'est le sujet aussi sur la
radicalisation sur le communautarisme
c'est le sujet aussi en matière
migratoire ce sont des sujets qu'il faut
absolument investir parce que quand non
on n'est pas pas en charge
démocratiquement
on les laisse à la rue si j'ose dire et
on les laisse aux extrêmes
je pense qu'il faut en parler de façon
apaisée sans jamais quitter des
principes démocratiques et républicains
merci bruno retailleau merci d'avoir été
notre invité ce matin sur europe 1 merci
beaucoup sonia mabrouk